vorrei iniziare questo tour
mostrando benin mali
cosa vedete molti di voi staranno
stando un maglione qualcuno di voi un
maglione di lana pochissimi di voi forse
un maglione di lana ha fatto a mano
in realtà avete tutti ragione e tutti
torto
quello che vedete è uno di quei tesori
che andrei recuperare anche in fondo al
mare
questo maglione è stato realizzato più
di 30 anni fa la mia nonna a mano per
mio padre per andare a sciare è ancora
oggi un indosso perché è di una qualità
eccezionale come siamo passati da questo
a questo tre anni fa quando mi occupavo
di progetti di cooperazione sviluppo in
vietnam
ho fatto una terribile scoperta ho visto
mucchi infiniti di vestiti abbandonati a
se stessi cimiteri di indumenti
abbandonati perché nessuno li voleva più
spesso riportati dall occidente e mi
sono chiesto ma anche i vestiti del mio
armadio faranno la stessa fine è davvero
sostenibile questo non esiste
un'alternativa
oggi vorrei raccontarvi una storia una
storia che riguarda la mia città a prato
da più di 100 anni arrivano rifiuti
tessili da tutto il mondo che vengono
divisi per colore e qualità trasformati
in una nuova fibra e successivamente in
un filato da artigiani specializzati che
si chiamano cenciaioli perché centro in
toscano vuol dire rifiuto tessile scarto
i cenciaioli in realtà li distingue
sempre per che hanno nella tasca dietro
posteriore un paio di forbici un
accendino anche se non tutti i loro fu
mano le forbici li servono per separare
le cuciture dalla maglia mentre
l'accendino riserve per vedere se c'è
una fibra sintetica all'interno della
composizione di quel capo la fibra
sintetica in realtà viene evitata per
dividerla dalle fibre vegetali e animali
che questo come viene fatto perché
bruciando il filo del capo
se fa il pallino significa che c'è del
sintetico e che quindi va messo da parte
mia sin da subito affascinato questa
storia il concetto di trasformare un
vecchio maglione una vecchia maglia in
una nuova risorsa me ne sono innamorato
come mi sono innamorato di questa
immagine
tutte le volte che entro in un capannone
a prato e mi emoziono perché vedo mucchi
infiniti di vestiti divisi per colore
qualità che sono pronti a essere
rigenerati pronti a essere trasformati
in una nuova fibra
bisogna iniziare abbandonare il modello
lineare di produzione che porta una
risorsa essere rifiuto perché altrimenti
un giorno rimarremo sommersi da tutte le
cose che abbiamo nell'armadio
bisogna iniziare a pensare in maniera
circolare un rifiuto deve essere una
nuova risorsa
però questo in realtà non è sufficiente
per avere una moda più sostenibile
bisogna anche iniziare a cambiare il
nostro approccio alle cose
il nostro modo di vedere un indumento
con l'avvento del fast fashion ci siamo
dimenticati delle emozioni mannaggia
siamo spinti a comprare ogni giorno ogni
mese ogni settimana ogni istante capi
che sappiamo benissimo che dopo meno di
un anno le avremmo già dimenticati
nell'armadio e poi gettati nei
cassonetti che troviamo spesso per
strada che strabordano di vestiti ne
abbiamo veramente gli armadi pieni ma
perché lo facciamo siamo spinti a
comprare comprare comprare ma perché
dobbiamo ribellarci un sistema economico
basato sui prezzi bassi sugli sconti e
non sul valore bisogna tornare a quel
maglioncino della nonna che sebbene si
possa macchiare strappare o oppure non
possa essere utilizzato comunque noi lo
indossiamo con piacere perché ci
racconta una storia perché ci racconta
un emozione questo è molto importante e
allo stesso tempo però oggi l'avremmo
già abbandonato perché dopo un mese come
maglioncino della nonna oggi l'avremmo
già sostituito con un altro dopo il
primo strappo per noi è così facile
adesso compriamo indossiamo buttiamo via
compriamo indossiamo buttiamo via
e così facendo abbiamo realizzato un
sistema che produce prodotti di
bassissima qualità che spesso nascono
già come rifiuto
bisogna cambiare questo sistema bisogna
tornare alle emozioni vivere un vestito
sentirlo nostro
mi ricordo che c'erano due cose che
facevo durante l'università perché
pensavo mi portassero fortuna
una era da demi la barba e un'altra
indossare una camicia azzurra regalata
dai mezzi ancora oggi indossare quella
camicia azzurra aiuta a ricordarmi dei
voti che ho preso durante l'università
oppure il giorno della discussione della
tesi
ecco secondo me è questa la prima forma
di sostenibilità tornare a quella
camicia azzurra tornare a quel
maglioncino di lana che io indosserei
anche se hanno soltanto una manica
perché mi raccontano un emozione
oggigiorno quando andiamo a comprare un
indumento non dobbiamo guardare solo al
prezzo ma dobbiamo chiederci se
effettivamente ne abbiamo bisogno e se
siamo intenzionati ad ascoltare ad amare
la storia che racconta la storia degli
artigiani che lo hanno realizzato
bisogna chiederci se siamo disposti a
comprare un tesoro che ci possiamo
portare sempre nel tempo perché
purtroppo oggi non ci siamo più abituati
una t shirt un maglione sono del
materiale usa e getta come se fosse una
bottiglietta di plastica o una forchetta
che si usa per mangiare riso freddo
sulla spiaggia d'estate bene questo non
ci deve più essere bisogna tornare alle
emozioni vivere un vestito sentirlo
nostro perché così facendo in realtà
avremo il nostro portafoglio più pieno e
porteremo un sorriso ogni volta che lo
indossiamo
questa è la rivoluzione gentile che
vorrei mettere in atto acquistare meno
acquistare meglio e portare con noi un
ricordo
oggi come quando faceva università porto
questa camicia azzurra perché
effettivamente spero mi porti fortuna è
che sia effettivamente all'inizio di una
rivoluzione
grazie mille
[Applauso]